et c'est justement les séries il ya des
preuves donc de la bougie zèle contre et
n'aura alors donnez vous à l'expliquer
l'épreuve de la boue alors elle un peu
spécial chez nous c'est une piscine donc
elles vont devoir s'enduire de boue et
mettre le maximum de boue dans un seau
c'est ça voilà exactement
alors si vous ne connaissez pas les
quads alors là cyril je regardais plus
tôt les deux participantes
oui il a été happé par les deux
participants alors ils vont rampe et
bien sûr sur le sol et imaginer que la
boue c'est denis brogniart les filles
allez-y en tout cas pour le prochain koh
lanta jeune et petit short en jeans
comme ça va je vais ça c'est pour moi
c'est cadeau attention c'est parti
ensuite il ya gilles verdez et jean
michel maire gilbert d ivoire est encore
30 secondes repartez laura repartez
rajouter 30 secondes rajouter quand je
regarde si c'est pas ça ça se fait pas
ça non halal à jouer le jeu allait et
allait continuer et les cantons
continuent et compte continuer elles
vont faire encore tu as quatre passages
ça fait du bien ça
allez on rajoute 30 secondes ou 30
secondes
allez-y allez-y et ça j'aime pas ça les
gens jean michel maire un peu de magie
et quand même joué le jeu et jean-michel
respecter gisèle s'il vous plaît merci
mais c'est bon loti lui met des claques
pour le fonds apporte quoi les plus
lents
j'ai l'impression qu'elle aura à la de
la boue même dans l'intérieur
non mais série n 8 7 6 5 4 3 car leur
est arrivé
attention alors alors maintenant alors
les laissant s'il vous plaît les sauts
attention normalement la nommer leurs
menus halal halal bollée ya une balance
via une balance s'il vous plaît
aidez-nous à la dame était d'abord celle
de gisèle le sceau de gizeh le sceau de
gisèle dama et la balle c'est vrai que
les moyens ici c'est pas terrible à la
balance alors est-ce qu alors la balance
je regarde on a combien il y a qu'est-ce
qu'ils sont cons ya 0,2 c'est une très
bonne idée cette balance à l'équilibré
très beaux ni très très bonne idée alesi
enlevé on enlevait c zéro et attention
le saut d'enora le souder n'aura à lever
le pied levé tout s'il vous plaît caméra
ah ouais c'est mieux c'est plus fort
oui il sera plus jamais contre le retour
de koh lanta après voilà mais là c'est
sûr qu il est content siraba laye s'est
fait plaisir
vous reverrez les images au ralenti sur
la fin ouais on était avec valérie
témoins vous regarderez skaff et gilles
verdez j'en dis pas qui a fait quoi que
je l'avais dit tout la vérité vous
regarderez on va regarder et nous qu'est
ce qu'il a fait il a pris un petit peu
de boue qui est peut-être qu'ils étaient
par terre alors attaquer il faut qu'à
luminaires la victoire pour jean michel
mais exactement qui reviennent pour leur
dit